we know that new plate material is being
formed and these these lithospheric
plates on the surface of the earth are
moving around and that might raise the
question in your brain what happens if
we kind of reverse things we know we
know the direction they're moving in
what does that tell us about where they
came from so let's just do the thought
experiment right now south america and
africa are moving away from each other
because of new because of new plate
material being created at the
mid-atlantic rift let's rewind it let's
bring them back together let's bring
them back together we know that india is
jamming into the eurasian plate right
now causing the himalayas to get higher
and higher what if we rewind that let's
bring india back down towards antarctica
same thing with australia we have new we
have new plate plate
material being formed between australia
and antarctica that's making the
continents move apart let's bring them
back together let's rewind let's rewind
the clock even north america it's not as
obvious from this diagram but if you
actually look at the gps data becomes
pretty obvious that north america right
now is kind of moving in a
in a counterclockwise rotation so let's
rewind it let's rewind it
into a let's go back
moving it in a clockwise direction let's
instead of eurasia going further away
from north america let's bring it back
together and so what you can imagine is
is a reality where india australia are
jammed down into south america into
sorry into antarctica south america and
africa are jammed together north america
is jammed in there and essentially
eurasia's also jammed in so it looks
like they're all kind of would clump
together if you go back a few hundred
million years
and based on literally
based on just that thought experiment
you could imagine at one point the
entire all of the continents on the
world were kind of merged into one super
continent and that super continent is
called pangaea
pangaea pan for entire whole and gia for
coming from gaia for the world and it
turns out that all of the evidence we've
seen actually does make us believe that
there was a supercontinent called well
we call it pangaea now obviously there
probably weren't things on the planet
calling it anything back then
well there were things back then but
nothing that not things that would
actually go and try to label continents
that we know of
but all of the evidence tells us that
pangaea existed about 200 to 300 million
years ago roughly two to maybe 250
million give or take years ago and i
want to be clear this was not the first
this was not the first
super continent to a large degree is
kind of the first the most recent super
continent that it's easiest for us to
construct because it it was the most
recent one but we believe that there
were other super continents before this
that if you go if you rewind even more
then your cut you would have to kind of
break up pangaea and it would reform but
now going back in time or that there
were several super continents in the
past that broke up reform broke up
reformed and the last time that we had a
super content was pangaea about 250
million years ago and now it's broken up
into our current day into our current
day
geography now i won't go into all of the
detail why we believe that there was a
pangaea about 250 million years ago or
this diagram tells us about 225 million
years ago give or take but i'll go into
some of the interesting evidence on a
very high level you have a lot of rock
commonalities between things that would
have had to combine during pangaean
probably the most interesting thing is
the fossil evidence
is the fossil evidence there's a whole
bunch of fossils and here are examples
of it from from species that were around
between 200 and 300 million years ago
and their fossils are found in very
specific place this animal right here
synognathus i hope i'm pronouncing that
right
synagogues that this this animals
fossils are only found in this area of
south america a nice clean band here and
this part of africa so not only does
south america look like it fits very
nicely kind of into africa
but the fossil evidence also makes it
look like there was a nice clean band
where this animal lived and where we
find the fossils so it really makes it
seem like these were connected at least
when this animal lived maybe on the
order of 250 million years ago this
species right over here its fossils are
found
in this area let me do in a color that
has more contrast
in this area right over here this plant
its fossils now this starts to connect a
lot of dots between a lot of content its
fossils are found in this entire area
across south south america africa
antarctica india and australia and so
not only not only does it look like the
continents kind of fit together in a
puzzle piece not only do we get it to a
configuration like this if we
essentially just rewind to the movement
that we're seeing now but the fossil
evidence also kind of confirms that they
fit together in this way this this
animal right here it
we find fossils on this nice stripe that
goes from africa through india all the
way to antarctica now this this only
gives us evidence of kind of the more
the the the southern hemisphere of
pangaea
but there is other evidence we find we
find kind of continuing mountain chains
between north america and europe we find
a rock evidence where you know just the
way we see the fossils kind of line up
nicely we see common rock that lines up
nicely between south america and africa
and other continents that were at once
connected so all of the evidence as far
as we can tell now does make us think
that there at one time was a pangaea and
for all we know all the all the
continents are going to keep moving and
maybe in at you know in a few hundred
million years we'll we'll have another
super continent who knows